after years of fun demands the Schneider
Kurtz of Justice League is finally on
his way to audiences was this version of
the movie always real why didn't we get
to see it in the first place and what
can we expect when it makes its debut
according to The Hollywood Reporter
Justice League went under two-week
hiatus in March 2017 so director Zack
Snyder could address a family matter in
May the tragic reason for the break was
revealed autumn Snyder the 20 year old
daughter of Zack Snyder and Justice
League producer Deborah Snyder had
tragically taken her own life by that
time Justice League was in the middle of
a rigorous post-production schedule in
order to meet a release date of November
17th but the studies announced that they
were stepping away from the film
permanently to grieve and heal the
decision to walk away he came after
Snyder screened of rough cuts which is
likely the origin of any Snyder cut
rumors and then decided and needed some
additional scenes screenwriter and
director Joss Whedon best known for
creating Buffy the Vampire Slayer
and directing the first two Avengers
films was hired to write and direct the
additional scenes after Zack Snyder left
the movie and gave up control Joss
Whedon got around 25 million dollars to
shoot a lot of new material and then
oversaw the theatrical release of
Justice League which the studio mandate
had run two hours or less although I
considered that just has to be a wealth
of unseen footage and had to go
somewhere in December 2019 slider
confirmed that some kind of Snyder cut
existed posting to vero an image of film
canisters labeled Zed s jl director's
cut running time 214 decoded that's the
Zack Snyder Justice League director's
cut running time 214 minutes that's a
three hour and 34 minutes well over
Warner Brothers 2 our demand electronic
musician junkie XL told Screen Rant in
2019 that he completed a score for this
extra long that Snyder approved version
versus aside occurred a glorified
extended edition DVD type deal Warner
Brothers producer Charles Roven told The
Washington Times that the math that
doesn't allow for extensive changes
between Snyder's vision and the Whedon's
and product
he explained let's just say 80 85 % of
the movie is what was originally shot
there's only so much you can do with the
other 15 20 percent of the movie yeah
not exactly an optimistic perspective I
see now that's called that's
betrayal I feel stung by that partly
because neither critics nor big DC fans
especially cared for Justice League and
partly because the public knew all about
the film's extraordinarily troubled
production history the legend of the
Snyder Kurt in the years after the film
hit theaters in November 2017 in 2019
Snyder cut demanding fans pulled 1170
dollars to hire a plane to fly over San
Diego comic-con trailing a banner that
read W be released SAS Snyder Kurt of
Justice League on November 17 2019 the
two-year anniversary of Justice League's
unveiling the hashtag released so Snyder
cut movement launched on that first day
more than 400,000 people caught on
Warner Brothers to release a cut of the
film that the studio wouldn't even
confirm existed in fact one of
Representatives wouldn't comment on any
plans for releasing Justice League at
all as early as 2018 a Warner
representative told The Wall Street
Journal that a company had no plans to
release a different version of Justice
League but where there is a will there's
a way and DC fans cast included turned
out to have a hell of a lot of well
surprisingly defiant in the face of
Warner Brothers indifference members of
the Justice League cast have repeatedly
spoken out about the Snyder cuts as
existence its quality and whether it
should be released when released the
Snyder Kurt became a trending topic and
rallying cry on social media in 2019 gal
gadot certainly put some pressure on
Warner Brothers executives in November
2019 she tweeted a picture of herself
captioned released a Snyder cut when a
flag followed Seuss and so did DC EU
actor Joe Manganiello using the hashtag
alongside an Instagram picture of
himself in his Deathstroke costume Ray
Fischer who played cyborg also echoed
this call-to-action though he later
deleted the tweet and then there's Jason
Momoa aka Aquaman who claims to have
actually seen some prints are the
directors original vision
he told MTV News I'm obviously indebted
to Warner's and DC and you know I don't
know how they feel about it but I mean
right as a fan I'm very very happy that
I got to see it Superman actor Henry
Cavill however claims not to know what
anybody is talking about during a press
tour for the waiter in December 2019 he
told a reporter I have not seen any
Snyder girl
I don't know if there is anything that
exists that is a Schneider cut I'm sure
there is footage out there which has
probably been pieced together over the
years we may never know the specific act
be it by a fan a cast member or even
Zack Snyder himself that finally made
the release of the Snyder Kurt at
possibility but one thing is for certain
somehow someone successfully brought it
back from the dead and kind of you see
if any sided cut of Justice League ever
did exist it was definitely a work
Prince or a rough cut with missing
effects incomplete and various other
holes are prevented it from an initial
release on the reel blend podcast
filmmaker and comics media lover Kevin
Smith said that the Snyder Kurt was
never a full-fledged film instead as he
explained it was a movie that like
people in production could watch and
fill in the blanks but was certainly not
meant for mass consumption that would
explain why it's not hitting HBO max
until 2021 just after the announcement
that some form of The Cider version of
the film would eventually make it to the
streaming platform The Hollywood
Reporter noted that the filmmaker has a
lot of work ahead of him
he's rehiring the original Justice
League post-production staff to get the
Snyder cut into releasable shape which
means a lot of editing and special
effects rendering is also speculation
Snyder will have to bring back the film
superhero cast to record new dialogue
for unfinished sequences the newly
produced material will be expensive
Warner Brothers has earmarked somewhere
between 20 million and 30 million
dollars to finish the movie well
honestly I think we're all gonna be dead
way before that check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
and TV shows are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and to the bail
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]